and you've got to ask yourself as you
watch the historic tragedy that is joe
biden's immigration policy what's the
point of this
nothing about it is an accident
obviously it's intentional joe biden did
it on purpose
but why
why would a president do this to his own
country
no sane first world nation opens its
borders to the world
promising the poorest people on the
planet that they can have endless free
taxpayer-funded services if they show up
and break your laws that's not just
stupid it's suicidal
for generations middle class americans
have had access to the best health care
in the world but not anymore that's over
for good our system cannot handle this
many destitute newcomers period
imagine what hospitals are going to look
like a year from now how about schools
what joe biden is doing now will change
this country forever so again
why is he doing it
there's only one plausible answer you're
not allowed to say it out loud cnn will
attack you if you do the social media
companies will shut you down the
southern poverty law center will call
you dangerous you could lose your bank
account the left will become completely
unhinged and hysterical and that's how
you know it's true they only censor the
true things nobody gets in trouble for
claiming the earth is flat
so it could be risky for us to explain
what's actually happening here but for
once we don't need to do that joe biden
himself has already done it for us
here's biden explaining the entire point
of mass immigration back in 2015 when he
was vice president
an unrelenting stream of immigration
non-stop
nonstop
folks like me who were
caucasian of european descent
for the first time in 2017 will be an
absolute minority in the united states
of america
absolute minority
fewer than 50 percent of the people in
america from then and on
will be
white european stock that's not a bad
thing that's as a source of our strength
an unrelenting stream of immigration but
why well joe biden just said it to
change the racial mix of the country
that's the reason to reduce the
political power of people whose
ancestors lived here and dramatically
increase the proportion of americans
newly arrived from the third world
and then biden went further he said that
non-white dna is the quote source of our
strength
imagine saying that
this is the language of eugenics it's
horrifying
but there's a reason biden said it in
political terms this policy is called
the great replacement the replacement of
legacy americans with more obedient
people from far away countries
they brag about it all the time but if
you dare to say it's happening they will
scream at you with maximum hysteria and
here you have joe biden confirming his
motive on tape with a smile on his face
no one who talks like this should ever
be the president of the united states
the president states has a moral
obligation to represent all americans
equally not just those of a specific
color
for four years remember they told me
that donald trump was a racist but has
anyone ever shown that trump in his
entire life said anything half as
disgusting as what joe biden said on
that tape
no no one's ever shown that
now you're not supposed to notice this
of course and to keep you from noticing
what joe biden is doing and why they are
as always accusing you
of their sins
here are two sitting members of congress
telling you that it's racist to enforce
immigration law watch
congress must do the work of
investigating and ensuring
accountability of the egregious and
white supremacist behavior of border
patrol agents in del rio texas
what we witness
takes us back hundreds of years
what we witnessed was worse than what we
witnessed in slavery
cowboys with their reins again
whipping
black people
haitians
into the water where they're scrambling
and falling down and all they're trying
to do is escape
from violence in their country
it's worse than slavery enforcing her
own laws that was maxine waters
everything she just said is a lie the
haitians now in texas aren't trying to
escape violence in their own country
they haven't been in haiti in years they
have been living in south america many
even had refugee status in south america
and countries like chile and brazil
but that wasn't good enough they waited
for joe biden to become president and
they came here for the free health care
and housing that joe biden promised them
so now they have arrived why wouldn't
they you would who wouldn't
so here's what it looks like tonight in
south texas
a stunning scene more reminiscent of a
third world country than the united
states over ten thousand migrants are
crammed underneath the international
bridge here after crossing illegally
into the united states many using sticks
plants and whatever they can find to
build shelter as they wait to be
processed by border patrol from above a
fox news drone reveals the size and
scope of the crisis showing a camp that
reached a population of 15 thousand at
its climax because of this
over the weekend we gained exclusive
access to a boat on the rio grande and
we watched as a constant stream of
hundreds of migrants cross the river
from mexico entering the united states
illegally hundreds at a time gathering
on the shoreline before walking to the
bridge
that looks like the country grew up in
no
we don't have to put up with this we
could solve it in a day the
administration could send these people
back immediately haitians are not bad
people a lot of them are great people
but we have no obligation to let them
into our country american citizens owe
no debt to haiti haiti was never an
american colony haiti has been an
independent country for more than 200
years since 1804
and for much of that time we have sent
haiti a whole lot of aid
so however sad and dysfunctional haiti
might be it is not our fault that's for
sure
and yet joe biden is now punishing
border patrol officers who tried to
enforce the law who dared to deter
haitians from entering this country
illegally
with their reigns
they weren't whips they were reigns
it doesn't matter to the bible
administration the officer's real crime
was trying to do their job trying to
stop illegal migration into this country
they've now been suspended they will
likely be fired
can you imagine
punishing law enforcement for enforcing
the law
this is insane
why do american citizens have a duty to
follow the law at this point that's an
honest question
people are going to start asking that
question
the white house spent most of today
calling those officers actions horrific
really how were they horrific the white
house never told us
that's because no one ever cared about
whether the whip was real or not
joe biden's press secretary is an
accomplished liar so she understands the
principle well
here she is in one of the great clips of
all time claiming that
unlike you
haitians do not need to show vaccination
cards why if somebody walks
into the country right across the river
did somebody ask them to see
their vaccination card well let me
explain to you again peter how our
process works as individuals as
individuals come across the border
and
they are uh both assessed for whether
they have uh any symptoms if they have
symptoms they are the intention is for
them to be quarantined that is our
process they're not intending to stay
here for a lengthy period of time
oh so
haitians entering our country illegally
from god knows where are not required to
show vaccination cards because quote
they're not intending to stay here for a
lengthy period of time
really so let's say you go out to a
restaurant in midtown manhattan do you
intend to stay in that restaurant for a
lengthy period of time for years no you
just want to have dinner
but in order to get inside you still
need to show a vaccination card
why oh because you were born here you're
not haitian so you don't get a pass
let's be honest none of these people are
ever going home
that's just true
according to the associated press quote
many haitian migrants camped in the
small texas border town are now being
released in the united states haitians
one official told the associated press
have been freed on a quote very very
large scale
oh of course
in recent days fox news has confirmed
that many of these haitians are not even
be giving being given court dates as
bill malugan just told us they'd be
giving something called advisory notices
requesting that they show up at some
point in the future any woman claiming
to be pregnant is immediately being
waived into the country no proof
necessary her child would be instantly
an american citizen
so who are these people exactly these
new americans well the administration
has no idea none they have no idea they
don't care
today jen saki again admitted she's not
even sure how many haitians have been
amended into the u.s and how many have
been deported all we know that several
of haitians trying to gain access to
this country appear to be violent this
was the scene at the airport in
port-au-prince just yesterday
the scene at port-au-prince airport in
haiti is volatile angry haitians dropped
off here by the biden administration
threw rocks and shoes at the plane that
carried them home
three u.s ice officers were reported
injured during incidents on the tarmac
throwing rocks at ice
officers the bite administration has
made it clear it's not going to do
anything about this of course the
governor of texas isn't doing much about
it either that would be greg abbott or
republican in a matter of moments greg
abbott could deploy the national guard
the texas national guard to shut off the
southern border completely protect his
state and the rest of the country he's
refused to do that instead he's deployed
just over one thousand of the
nineteen thousand troops he controls
why is that why not save the country if
you have the power to do that why not
save your own state
we don't know greg abbott refused to
come on the show and tell us the moment
we'll speak to one of his primary
opponents about what should be done to
protect all of us hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else